the movie opens up with Teresa tree
gelbman a university student who's as
attractive as her nickname is stupid
waking up disoriented in the dorm room
of her classmate Carter Davis she finds
herself wearing his clothes after a
night of drunken partying as the two
talk we get to know that it's tree's
birthday today but she doesn't seem too
excited about it she even ignores a
phone call from her father suggesting
that they have a strained relationship
after a while tree leaves Carter's room
and heads back to her own on the way she
notices several students going about
their day they are walking chatting and
doing things a normal student would do
when tree reaches her dorm her roommate
Lori Spangler gives her a cupcake as a
birthday present however she throws it
in the bin citing that it has too many
carbs after attending her classes and a
sorority meeting tree decides to visit
her boyfriend Dr Gregory Butler's office
at the campus hospital as she arrives
she unexpectedly runs into Lori who
happens to be a nurse at the same
Hospital Lori says that she is concerned
about tree's secret affair with a doctor
she believes that it is unethical and
wrong but tree brushes off Lori's
concerns and tells her to mind her own
business that night as she leaves for a
party she is surprisingly followed by a
figure wearing a mask of the school
mascot tree notices him and tries to run
away but ends up falling to the ground
taking full advantage of this the
mysterious figure catches up to her and
murders her In Cold Blood the next
second tree wakes up in Carter's bed and
assumes that it was just a bad dream
however as she proceeds to leave she
realizes that the events from her
nightmare are repeating themselves
Carter says the same things he said
earlier and when tree goes outside she
notices the same students doing the same
activities as in her nightmare moreover
when she reaches her dorm Lori is
waiting for her with a cupcake the day
is Monday the 18th of September just
like in her nightmare this makes tree
anxious so she decides to be a bit more
careful later on her way to the party
she avoids taking the tunnel and reaches
the venue safely but unfortunately she
is chatting with one of her friends the
mysterious figure arrives at the scene
and kills both of them in the next scene
tree again wakes up in Carter's dorm
wearing his clothes realizing that the
day has been reset due to her death she
frantically leaves for her dorm on
reaching it she tells her roommate Lori
about all that's been happening to her
but the latter brushes her off and asks
her to relax following this tree locks
herself in her room she barricades her
door and Boards up her Windows hoping
that the killer won't be able to come
inside but to her horror he has already
managed to get inside in the blink of an
eye he attacks her from behind and kills
her off as expected the day is reset and
tree once again wakes up in her friend's
room not knowing what to do she invites
Carter for lunch and tells him
everything the confused guy expectedly
doesn't believe any of it but just make
her feel good he decides to help her
Carter speculates that perhaps tree's
recurring dreams have something to do
with her birthday they then make a list
of people who might have a motive to
kill her Carter suggests that she can
take advantage of the loop since it
gives her unlimited chances to figure
out who the Killer is tree absolutely
loves the idea so she spends the next
several iterations trailing people she
considers suspects but each time she
gets killed by the masked killer after
waking from a loop where she is
bludgeoned tree is unable to walk and
she passes out Carter immediately rushes
her to the hospital and when she wakes
up Dr Gregory reveals her medical
reports show evidence of recovery from
multiple traumatic injuries these
injuries are so severe that she should
be dead right now hearing this true
figures out that the injuries she
sustained from the previous deaths in
her dreams are incurring real physical
damage this means that if she doesn't
solve the situation soon her body will
get weaker by the day and she might end
up dying in her sleep fearing for her
life tree decides to flee from the
hospital she sneaks into Gregory's
office and steals his car keys but as
she is trying to escape the masked
killer suddenly shows up poor Gregory
also arrives at the wrong time and he is
immediately killed meanwhile tree rushes
for her life and somehow manages to flee
from the hospital just as she thinks she
made it out alive and starts to
celebrate she is stopped by the police
for speeding tree figures out that it
might be better for her if she is locked
up in a jail cell that way she will be
away from the killer hence she lies to
the officer that she was driving under
the influence the latter buys it and
makes her sit in the police car but
right then the killer arrives at the
scene and runs the officer over he then
sets the car on fire and kills her
burning trees the killer must be a
stoner you're right that sucked
following this tree wakes up in Carter's
bed again he inquires why she was
screaming in her sleep to which she
frantically responds that she keeps
getting murdered by an unknown person
Carter who doesn't remember their
previous meeting believes that she is
joking but when she predicts the day's
events currently he is left in utter
shock all this time she keeps ignoring
her father's calls tree reveals that she
was really close to her mother who
shared a birthday with her however three
years ago she tragically passed away and
this severed her relationship with her
father later as the two are talking at
an Eatery they see a local news report
on John
he is a serial killer who murdered six
female victims tombs was the subject of
Nationwide five-month-long Pursuit and
he is currently being held at the campus
hospital it is revealed that he was
involved in a shooting of a local police
officer and is being treated for a
gunshot wound after the news report ends
tree puts two and two together and
concludes that tombs is the masked
killer she immediately rushes to the
hospital and warns the employees there
that tombs is going to escape however it
is too late as when she reaches the room
she finds a dead police officer the
masked man also arrives there and starts
chasing tree with a gun he then takes
off his mask and almost kills her but
Carter intervenes on time and rescues
her unfortunately he pays the price and
gets killed by tombs The Psychotic
killer then chases tree to a nearby Bell
Tower and eventually catches up to her
but this time our protagonist is well
prepared she swings a crowbar at his
head and knocks him out however as tree
prepares to kill tombs she realizes that
if she doesn't reset the day her best
friend Carter will remain Dead Forever
so she reluctantly runs to the top of
the tower and commits the unthinkable as
soon as she wakes up in Carter's room
she hugs him affectionately and thanks
him for saving her life Carter doesn't
understand what's going on but he
accepts the hug anyway it turns out that
he's had a major crush on her for years
meanwhile tree is now more confident
about solving her murder mystery since
she knows the identity of her killer she
proceeds happily through the day tree
signs this Optical warning campaign
petition for the girl that asks for her
signature every dream She lays a pillow
out for the guy that passes out while
talking to his friends she tells Tim the
guy that she went out on a date with
that she knows he likes guys and he
should not try to be something that he
is not she also tells him that love is
love later she reaches her dorm and
apologizes to Lori for being a terrible
roommate tree also ends her affair with
her married Professor Gregory she says
that she can't change what she did in
the past but she wishes to try to be a
better person today at the uptight
sorority meeting tree arrives with fried
high calorie food and protects one of
her friends from being that when Carter
comes to the meeting to see her she
unexpectedly kisses him and asks him out
after the sorority meeting tree arrives
at the restaurant where her dad is
waiting for her she apologizes to him
for being late and the two finally talk
after years of being apart tree explains
that she misses her mom so much that she
had started avoiding her birthdays for
her the 18th of September is the worst
day of the year tree further adds that
it hasn't been easier but it has been
much worse all the running and hiding
has made her miserable tree then gets
emotional and apologizes to her dad for
always ignoring him she promises that
she will be a better daughter from now
on after mending her relationship with
her father tree gets ready to face the
killer she goes to the campus hospital
where tombs is being kept and steals the
gun from the policeman guarding the room
she tells him the tombs is going to
escape and makes him get reinforcements
once alone tree confronts her killer and
finally shoots him dead after this she
sneaks quietly out of the hospital and
goes to meet her new boyfriend Carter
that night tree decides to celebrate
both her Victory and her birthday at the
same time she brings the cupcake given
by Lori blows out the candles and eats
it the next second tree shockingly wakes
up in Carter's bed the loop is somehow
still intact indicating that tombs was
not the masked killer worried tree
rushes out of the room and heads to her
dorm she then starts packing her
belongings with the intent of running
away at the same time her roommate Lori
approaches her with the cupcake seeing
it tree concludes something shocking the
previous leap was the only time she had
ever eaten a cupcake since she died
right after it tree concludes that Lori
had given her a poisoned cupcake
following this the movie goes into a
flashback in her previous numerous
streams when tree threw the poisoned
cupcake in the trash Lori decided to
kill her using a different method so she
put on a scary mask and started her
reign of terror she always framed John
tombs as he was an easy scapegout back
in the present when tree confronts Lori
about all of this the latter finally
comes clean she admits that she is also
having an affair with the handsome
Doctor Gregory but every time she is
with him he'll always talks about tree
indicating that he prefers her that
strove Lori mad with jealousy so she
decided to take matters into her own
hands her ultimate plan was to kill tree
then kill Dr Gregory's wife so that she
could live with him happily after
revealing all this Lori attacks tree and
an intense struggle follows they go back
and forth at each other for a while but
in the end it is tree who prevails by
shoving The Poisoned cupcake in Lori's
mouth and kicking her at the Second
Story window the impact kills the evil
girl on the spot in the final scene tree
wakes up in Carter's room and finds her
phone ringing with the same happy
birthday tune this freaks her out and
the same events from her dreams start
unfolding but to her relief Carter
admits that he was just playing a prank
on her and it is the 19th of September
trauma's not funny Carter you dick hole
the movie ends as the two share a
romantic kiss subscribe for more videos
like this turn on notifications and
leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching